hello welcome to Reykjavik in Iceland
you can tell that something is about to
happen because journalists are gathering
and we are about to see world leaders
from across Europe descending on this
place for the fourth ever Council of
Europe Summit there is one big item on
the agenda unsurprising the war in
Ukraine we are going to see countries
pledging again their support we've seen
plenty of countries including Britain
stepping up their support in the last
few days in a couple of hours they're
going to be passing um here world
leaders as I say from across Europe
including Rishi sunak Emmanuel macron
Olaf Schultz of Germany
um we're hoping they're going to stop
and have a chat to us journalists
they're also going to be using this as
an opportunity to push
um I think on their domestic agendas
Rishi sunak really wants to talk about
immigration this is something he's
facing a lot of pressure on he's
weakened by the local election results
and he wants to show that he can be
tough and robust on immigration so that
is a message that Rishi sunak is going
to want to get across today but the
broader focus unsurprisingly is on
Ukraine